All right.
My friends understand that Florida has been
caught hiding, not reporting Corona virus
deaths, and it's absolutely sickening and
it will lead to more people dying for about
10 days now.
Medical experts have been expecting Florida's
corona virus deaths to spike.
Why?
Well, because Florida started reopening beaches
10 days ago.
They have a totally incompetent Republican
governor, Ron DeSantis.
He's proven himself to be absolutely clueless.
We know Florida has the fifth oldest median
age in the country.
Their population, the median age, is the fifth
oldest in the country.
And Corona virus, by a large margin, is disproportionately
affecting older people.
And yet, the Florida death numbers, just like
they never really got that bad.
You look at the case numbers.
They're not testing that much.
You see about 33000 cases.
OK.
That that's a lot.
But for a state with more than 21 million
people, that case numbers are kind of low.
That could just be testing.
But then you see the deaths and somehow the
official corona virus death toll in Florida
was as of the moment where we looked at it,
1268 deaths.
Now, it would be fantastic if that were the
case.
It didn't make sense.
The numbers just didn't pass the sniff test,
given the size of Florida and the policies
and the number of population, densely populated
areas.
And now we have the answer.
Florida officials have been withholding.
They've just been not releasing the data from
medical examiners about coronavirus deaths
for more than a week now.
The Hill reports that Stephen Nelson, the
chairman of the state medical examiner's commission,
said to the Tampa Bay Times the state Health
Department intervened and they told me they
are going to remove the causes of death in
case descriptions for mortality data, which
will hold down the official death toll from
Corona virus in Florida.
Now, many Republicans want to argue it's fine
to reopen.
Shut downs aren't necessary.
They support it by saying, look, we don't
have that many deaths here in Florida.
And yet they're lying about the deaths.
They are hiding the deaths, according to this
report.
Not only is this disrespectful to people who
have lost their lives, it's disrespectful
to people who seeing these fake numbers will
go outside instead of staying home, will not
wear a mask instead of wearing a mask, will
go in protest and lobby for opening instead
of understanding why it is that we're doing
what we're doing.
So when you look at the measures that can
be taken to deal with the virus, stay at home
orders, closing businesses, social distancing
masks, what Florida has chosen to do is just
lie about the number of people dying claim
nobody's dying.
It will also backfire, by the way, because
if you use fake numbers to support opening
up when you shouldn't, that will drive a crazy
explosion in the number of cases and deaths
you would imagine eventually it would get
out no matter what.
Well, here we have one report.
They are blowing the whistle and saying that
the number is fake and it never made sense
on.
I'm trying to think if it was on the show
or on livestreams a week and a half ago, I
was saying that the Florida numbers should
be spiking.
OK.
Heat and humidity may play a role in slowing
the spread.
But from the studies we've seen, it's only
a minor role, though.
It's only makes a little bit of a difference.
Where are Florida's deaths?
What is going on?
And boom incomes.
A whistleblower who says they're just not
reporting them.
If this is true and there's every indication
that it is, it is disgusting, sick and it
will lead to even
more death.